hello way to welcome to this video
playing after kofta ok we can get a roxy
prolly by transposition so as a
well-known brand online in 95 here's an
interesting move ok what I can
doesn't make a difference here right
yeah asics it's less precisely and now
95 leads into a super draw ish ending
that oligarch likes to play yeah this is
my way of playing it is a bit more
interesting even though even though um
you should probably you should probably
know it better than I do because I don't
know any much more than up to this I
think black has too high of 75 stuff he
seems to know everything and playing
very quickly maybe f force writer I
don't know really it's been a long time
since I checked this line
baby hmm I was just thinking f4 could be
a move for black but f1 looks a bit it's
probably probably not great he gets the
e5 square but i also get e for boots
probably not great yeah 95 was one thing
i had considered okay let's do this
maybe now some light f6 i-94
hmm I guess to do something fairly
concrete and quickly if I get to play g5
I think that is going to be annoying
[Music]
it's also interesting trying to take and
play the night reform okay let's do this
contending 95 we can take on c3 now and
check me out no I'm not quite sure why I
cannot take maybe it should be three
stuff but I want to play this move
anyway so let's do it there's no reason
not to play it and once b5 happens I
would have played it in any case almost
they don t have seven something like
that he takes it okay I thought the
should see five now is good isn't it he
takes their I take the 60 it must be
greater that good is there some tactics
and I'm missing I mean if there is the
tactic it's just excellent for wild
place see five next move and the bishop
covers c5 and f4 and the sea porn is
extremely strong and it's an extra bone
I mean you know that should work
there's no tective
that whole line is ok for black if you
know it really well I don't really know
it too well from the whites point of
here ok so i think c5 anyway maybe you
would be 4i bishops III wants to play ok
it's it's a pay attention a little bit
and see to prevent this um well okay and
[Music]
it's not that terrible that what happens
I mean you can almost check the exchange
look for loop default check this is an
idea we do this actually for Luke's III
takes King takes I just just goes goes
off
you
I didn't play that well I mean in the
view of that time when I really played
very sloppily and someone isn't easy
time warning
black realize think I didn't allow
anything and too much but it wasn't
wasn't all that all that good yet
technically speaking I'm fairly shredded
so this is the theoretical position for
sure I think black holes defy a bit i'm
i'm not certain there are some there I
dd5 ideas he played that rather quickly
though so it's may be so normal yeah
this is impossible move but I thought
that I mean I get this square as well it
should be okay for me look Sadie I went
f4 and he always yeah it can always do
this so what the engine gives here but
this must be a slight advantage for
white yeah my bishop is stronger and
it's Paul some pawn structure is a bit
compromised yeah no I mean taking an
engine wants to take it yeah I still
like this move it's a good strategic
move this yeah probably doesn't work
simply now this definitely didn't work
and this is can cannot be great him with
before okay King d3 is interesting I was
just thinking take to take
King b3 is stronger oops okay now you're
threatening to take interesting ok and
here it's more less winning also on the
clock and I don't eat it I played a
little bits locally ok the engine always
thinks i'm winning it I wasn't quite
sure looked a little bit a little bit
strange to me ok guys thanks for
watching